sorry you coming here today yes MH and
Allah you see it as a sign you mean yeah
100% what's more than this bro forget
that forget that sh are you telling me
it's a coincidence that brother randomly
goes I answer his
question where is he is he here or
no but he I'm pretty sure he heard me
and me my friend talk listen
listen dep for you think that there
something listen there's something
further than this how come how did we
come here I think today you should go
home and you forgot how to pray we'll
give you a where's our m g I have a m at
home one of these not one of oh this is
the the teaching M okay not these Ms
brother this is a special M there we go
so this is from us but do you do the
same thing with your atheist friend when
he comes and says to you no no no they
cannot be a god do you say it makes
sense now but when I leave it might not
make sense do you say that to him uh no
but they used to say it to him yes good
but no no but I accept that I'm biased
is it important to him though important
to who to Allah important was important
to Allah that you listen to him no
because of who he
is Allah Allah no Allah doesn't need us
it's because of who he is we worship
Allah because of who he is not because
of what he does for us you know name me
someone famous
Ronaldo okay if you see Ronaldo would
you get excited this not an answer to
your question but it's about what you
said so when I was uh converted I used
to pray here as well on the Fridays
inshah you're going to pray again who
knows maybe in
and um every time I prayed for about
maybe six months I prayed sometimes like
once a day maybe Max every time I prayed
there was just I think the spiritual
aspect is missing here it's because it's
everything's become too logical and in
Islam it's like like not everything's
logic of course it's aspect but we
believe IM let me tell I can bring you
uncles full-blown old uncles Somali or
Kurdish or Bengali uncles I promise you
nobody can sway their faith if a aist
came and said a big bang this say yeah
shut up man I don't know what you're
talking about you crazy
man they and this shows me this is where
I noticed you know some
people is from Allah it's not a logical
thing brothers and sisters it is the
winter season in the UK today in my
house my boiler broke and the house was
freezing cold my kids are wearing
jackets I'm trying to find heating and
as a father I'm trying to make sure my
kids my wife are War imagine the people
around the world I'm working with one om
say 100% donation policy charity who are
helping Syria Lebanon and Afghanistan
people who are freezing to death intense
brothers and sisters donate whatever you
can because today's experience with me
showed me Subhan Allah how vulnerable we
are and just made me remember those
people who are in need whatever you
donate guys even if it is1 help those
people in those countries Char today
you're going to be short of Islam in we
will see we will see by the way if if
the if you are inshah if you are
convinced with our answer if you find
the truth you will accept to be Muslim
again correct yes I've done before so I
think yeah what's the main reason you
left Islam I don't think it's a logical
reason bro why I went for Islam No no
why did you leave Islam like what's the
main no it's not a logical reason it's
not it was it was a process of slowly
what no what what was it there has to be
something cuz I don't think it's logical
cuz we've discussed a logical for in
still don't believe in free will I still
don't no no okay but what's what's we
don't have we don't have the believe in
the absolute free will uh well I chose
no I I don't choose to believe it I
believe it did you choose to think like
this but that's not free will that's the
determinist wait wait but are you listen
you confus yourself now you just
contradict now you said now I believe
this and then you said you choose to
believe this no no I said I don't choose
to believe it I believe it oh okay so
that's don't so you don't believe in
Free Will no I don't I don't no it's
fine so you don't believe in uh you
don't believe in Free Will you believe
in
determinism I don't believe yeah I don't
believe in Free Will I believe in but if
we go back to necessary being his
attribute he has to be the old just he
has to be it's a necessity that's his NE
his attributes and Ne Necessities as
well yeah necessary so meaning he has to
be the all just because if there is
hellfire and Heaven that means he has to
judge us and give test to us in such a
fair way that's what Allah says in the
Quran we will never test you with
something that you cannot burden meaning
that he's that's his justice meaning he
cannot test you with something that
you're like I cannot deal with this and
it's going to cause you to break no
Allah says everyone will be tested in a
specific way so therefore he has to be
just and only Justice can apply is
number one by his attribute he has to be
the all knowing which is he knows number
two two he has to give you free will if
he's not giving you free will I'm a
puppet I'm a like a robot no I have free
will so that's why we say we're
compatibilists meaning we believe in
predestiny and we believe in free will
they work in in conjunction with one
another yeah exactly so compatib yeah I
I understand that I I I think that's
perfectly reasonable if you believe in
free will then you can still believe in
determinism we're saying by the
necessity of God Almighty existence by
the attributes we given him he is Allah
and by that him being the all just and
the all knowing necessitates that you
have to have because he's all knowing
there has to be destiny predestiny that
he knows number two because of his
Justice there has to be free will so
meaning what we have right now is the
perfect balance of God Almighty knowing
everything and we have given free will
there is not oppression on
anybody that makes sense that should
answer your question because based on
based on based on his based on him
existing and being the all just and all
knowing it necessitates like we said
before we have DNA how does he how does
he necessitate free will because because
he's a necessary being he's but what
does the free will have to be have to
because he's the all just and all
knowing so you know sometimes people
come and say if God is all loving we say
no God is Not only all loving that's a
Christian concept do you get if he's all
loving then why does he do evil does it
mean he wants we don't believe that
because we say God is also all wise
meaning there are certain things that he
does you don't understand for example um
if my son is if I had a son and he was
running towards the fire and the closest
thing I could do to stop is by kicking
him cuz I got long legs yeah I kick him
and he falls down he starts crying the
action is he going to think my dad is a
good good father or bad father he's
going to think you're a bad father why
because you kicked him in the fire okay
or out of the fire away from the fire
but in his head he's like my dad kicked
me he doesn't know the fire would burn
him he's seen the action of what I'm
doing but my wisdom necessitates what I
just saved you by kicking you cuz that
kick will recover but you and the fire
are going to die so we say God is the
most wise that's why there's certain
things he does for example the problem
of evil why do people die why does
cancer why does this why does Co why is
this earthquakes because we say God is
the all knowing there is a Hereafter and
God is Not unjust to anybody those who
died in a cancer or this that they will
be all judged in a just manner because
but but that's but that's within the the
view of Islam that's not within the like
you haven't proven not necessarily this
is take Islam to a side because of God's
attributes it necessitates that let's
put Islam to a side but it doesn't
necessitate free will of course it does
because I don't see the link you know if
he said if there is Justice yeah if God
is All Justice yeah all just in what but
I I don't what do you mean with all just
exactly all just meaning there has to be
Justice like you know when you go and
somebody like for example somebody
killed someone and you killed him that's
Justice served he killed a man an eye
for an eye justice but we're seeing the
most perfect form of the most the most
perfect form of justice is what is God
Almighty applying that in this world by
the Sharia and secondly in the Hereafter
the ultimate Justice in the Hereafter
why because someone like King leopard II
killed 10 million congales 10 million
congales if we kill him he only suffice
for one what about the
999 uh 9,
999,000 what about that many people how
is that Allah says in the Quran when
they enter the fire we will replace the
skin to taste of punishment again we can
only apply all Justice in the Hereafter
not in this so he has to be the most
just because when you've been wrong and
oppressed or people in Palestine the
question we need to ask one second one
second I am distracted Sor no no no it's
no problem when for example the people
in Palestine they being they're
suffering they have been under
oppression yeah genocide yeah so do you
think Benjamin Netanyahu the Satan is's
just going to get away with it yeah an
atheistic worldview it's just like yeah
I mean he's he in that way that that way
he's Justified it's just a re
rearrangement for atoms you know it's
just like me having water there's no
value to human life but ultimate Justice
is what he will be questioned and he
will suffer the consequences in the best
Ultimate Justice in the Hereafter MH it
necessitates that to
happen because of who I understand what
you because of who Allah is it
necessitates that so that's why that's
what we talking about when you believe
in the you accepted with us that about
the independent being you accepted so
far and you accept that this independent
being has certain characteristics a
being has characteristics has power has
knowledge to create this universe and
has the will to create this universe
since there are many atrocities and
things that happen in this universe that
means that necess necess God has to be
just and fair being just and fair based
on what based on what when God is that
means someone deserve appraise and
someone deserve punishment those who
deserve to be praised because they have
done something good those who deserve
punishment because they have done
something bad that goes back to what MH
to people choose to do something good
and people choose to do something bad
yeah that's how it is so go is basically
we say establish the throne and then
decorate yeah because they say put the
throne in the middle and then you
decorate around
it let's establish this now here God and
then the other things comes with it mhm
you wanted you neglect for example and
you negate the the free will yeah and
then and end up negating the existence
of God now with your own logic we prove
to you that God
exists it has to go back to refute the
con the concept of the Free Will of the
Free Will so it has goes vice versa why
not doesn't make sense yeah yeah it
makes sense it makes sense so if it
makes sense if it makesense no it yeah
if it makes sense don't say it makes
sense now yeah but I do because why I
try to explain it but I can't explain to
but you do the same thing with your
atheist friend when he comes and says to
you no no no they cannot be a god do you
say it makes sense now but when I leave
it might not make sense do you say that
to him uh no but I used to say it to him
yes good but no no but I accept that I'm
biased okay good but that's that's
that's that's that's issue being biased
means that you're saying if I say to you
this is a bottle because of your bias
you're going to say no maybe it's not
bottle mhm it's a chicken would that
logically follow that if I'm telling you
it's a bottle and you're like I'm only
saying yes now I feel like you're
oversimplifying it it's it's not that
easy it is that simple don't you're comp
comp can I compfy I'm complicating it
comp I'll give you uh a foru yeah uh
example example yeah so you have
believed in Islam for how long uh 11
years 11 years okay so if right now
someone comes along and tells you
something that kind of sounds logical
yeah I wholeheartedly believe that you
will say the same about what he says as
you to me right now or as me to you so
you will say it sounds logical but I
can't accept it I I can't accept it like
this because I have I have thought 11
years some you how many things people
say to him this guy this guy is being
being targeted left right and Center by
the people yeah all all kind of things
atheists Jews and
whatever whatever and I've seen it yeah
the idea is we we we get this the point
is we need to know where's what's where
is our ground we have we should have a
firm ground first before we do anything
else you are standing on a shaking
ground sry to say oh yeah yeah of course
I'm still I'm still searching my way why
standing the shaking ground that's why
everyone and the one who standing
shaking ground just like a boat on a on
a on a water I know could drive you here
and there here and that's how
this is the problem that facing now now
we say to you okay before you instead of
being on that boat come and be on a firm
ground that we are talking about the
firm ground is basically this are using
you have this have this machine yeah
your your brain and by the way let me on
a side yeah that's a joke on a side yeah
they said there is a man wasn't using
his brain and someone was you know was
always you know they said they open
Japanese brain guy and then they found
all these you know electronics and
things like that they oh this guy and
the other guy they open his brain German
guy they found oh all these mechanics
and cars and things like this they open
this guy who never used his brain they
found a string just a single string so
they cut the string and then they fell
the earing fell
down the string was holding the ears
it's a joke on the side my point is you
have a brain you don't have the string
to hold the ears you have a brain you
could use it so this this
brain we have it for a reason M to
understand things around us to think not
toally so since we understand what the
meaning of having a logical arguments to
stand on we're saying to you what bases
the one who negate the existence of God
based on what logical argument simple
yeah okay if they don't have let's talk
about the things that we have we told
you based on our logic now the things
either either impossible existence mhm
which is is is never there is never will
be there because contradict the the
logic mhm like square circle the square
circle or C square whatever yeah or the
the possible beings like us which are we
are dependent on on the things around us
and since this universe is limited and
finite that means it is dependent based
on our own logical arguments but on our
own understand on our own reasoning yeah
that since it is dependent dependent on
what
but now when you say to me dependent on
something dependent and that's you I go
go further and then go to infinite
that's why we say it has to have a
starting point that starting point is
the independent being that's the one who
initiate the
creation so that's independent being
based on neurologic I'm talking about
very ground there's no no one can debunk
this no one on earth can debunk this
fact yeah no one you bring all atheist
on Earth you bring anyone you name it
they cannot debunk this they will talk
nonsense here and there they will talk
all these small things we're talking
about the core of the faith the core of
of the faith of Islam which is God so
that's why we say since this universe
exist it must have someone or a being
that created it yeah and that is the
independent one and it should have since
it's a being it's a it's a thing it has
characteristics because if it doesn't
have any characteristics nothing it
doesn't exist okay so since it has
characteristics it has power to create
thise that's logic correct it has
knowledge to create this universe that's
logic and it has a will because since it
has knowledge that means has a will to
decide mhm yeah to decide to do it or
not to do it
yeah since it has a we're talking about
God you want to to name it something
else it's God we name it as we Muslim we
say Allah means the the one God and it
has to be one as adding to this by the
way yeah yeah yeah you forgot to say
that and it has to be one it has to be
one and it has to be one not not plural
yeah cuz you can't have you can't have
two necessary beings yeah okay yeah can
I um yeah I want to delve deeper in uh
into free will if you'd like before we
go to the free will yeah listen I told
you if you this mhm which already been
debunked with you finished but the Free
Will is already on now since this higher
being before that since this higher
being is all power all knowing has
independent will since there are things
which is happening on Earth we born in a
client even animals born in a client
believing in Justice there's some
justice yeah if you either two monkeys
if you give one one uh one fruit here
and two fruits there then the monkey
will throw it because feel being injust
being treated injust and it happened
they did this experience with monkeys
let alone a human being yeah so we
believe there is Justice yeah so since
there is Justice yeah where is it since
we talking about the the absolute higher
being the creator of this you know in
two days it should be
just part of his
characteristics as a necessity as a
necessity being that it has to have a
three it has should be it should be
Justice M since it's Justice he will
judge us based on
what if someone is just yeah judging us
based on what so someone will say oh you
know I'm a criminal I killed people so
what's the so what God will do to us we
punish best know say you you determined
me to be like that why I'm punished for
things I'm dist for yeah and that's why
the group of who call them they call
they said we are forced to do other
things we have nothing no free will
whatsoever we are created like this to
do what we do yeah so that's why Islam
refutes this and there is another type
of deviant group called which is they
believe in absolute Free Will and Allah
has nothing to do with it and those are
two Extremes in Islam and Islam is in
the middle those ones who say we have no
free will we say no Islam says how Allah
will judge us how Allah will punish us
if if if we don't have free will and at
the same time we say we don't have an
absolute free will to decide whatever
want to do actually again that's not
part of the of we say everything was
decreed by Allah now at the point when
you are deciding to do the right and the
wrong things when you choose to do the
right thing yeah then God will praise
you and God deserve deserve to give you
a reward and you deserve to go Paradise
if you if you choose to do the wrong
things if you choose to harm others if
you choose to do things you cannot get
away even if you get away from this
world like some people who go like
what's his name um uh his hand he killed
millions of people and he got he died
yeah he died and even he was told the
more he sleep with women that he would
have more life Etc so he was thinking
doing all these things to extend his
life eventually he died he got away from
the punishment from killing millions of
people he burned City whole cities
totally killed everyone there what is
the Justice yeah how how does it follow
that ultimate power can you imagine have
you seen the video that do you believe
he will he will be he will burn in yes
of course did he but did he receive
Islam do you know he receive okay if he
didn't receive Islam this is why Justice
comes in we believe that if someone
didn't hear the message of Islam he will
be tested on the day of judgment he will
be tested on the day of judgment what do
you mean very simple someone who hasn't
reached the age of puberty somebody who
is insane oh you will not be tested you
mean he will be tested on the day of Jud
because for justice God is going to give
them everybody who didn't receive Islam
in the correct way will be judged you
might have a Christian and atheist a
Hindu and Muslim or tested sorry
in a specific way Allah will come to
them they won't see Allah Allah will
come to them and bring the Hell Fire it
will look like hell fire but rather it
is Paradise God Almighty will say jump
in it's it's it's Paradise yeah it's a
test because you're going to see fire so
now this is a matter of am I going to
trust what's being said to me and put my
taul is having trust in God and jump the
ones who jump will see as Paradise the
ones who don't will end up in Hell Fire
him why because we went through a test
in this life where we had to have trust
in God when we did not see him yeah we
had to believe in a Hellfire and
Paradise so therefore it is only fair
how is it fair that somebody a Hindu who
hasn't heard about Islam gets this go
straight into Paradise no he has to be
tested and his test is Allah will tell
him I am your Lord that's the fire jump
in but rather you find this paradise if
you believe in his because you have to
believe in his word if you believe in
his word you show his loyalty anded in
him and you will find it as Paradise if
you reject it you rejected it like when
Allah told him to
he said no he into disbelief why because
he ascribed the mistake to Allah so what
we're saying is why is that there
because Allah the most just would you
ever F any why is it important to him
though important to who to Allah what
important what's important to Allah that
you listen to him no because of who he
is to Allah to no Allah doesn't need us
it's because of who he is we worship
Allah because of who he is not because
of what he does for us you know name me
someone famous Ronaldo
okay if you see Ronaldo would you get
excited yeah okay would you be like oh
my gosh that's Ronaldo would you want to
go next to him would you be very careful
how you approach him yeah okay would you
say to monardo can I take a picture with
you yeah of course yeah okay would you
be extra respectful towards him mhm
extra thing if he said to you listen
let's go and eat together oh my gosh if
he told you sit down here sit down here
or do this you will listen to him yeah
yeah what has Ronaldo done for you has
he paid for your bills mhm what
because I would get something out of it
that's the only reason okay that's a
picture but even if you did not get a
picture because of who he is is a
respect you show him Ronaldo has done
nothing for you does Ronaldo make your
heartbeat no does Ronaldo um have these
white cells in your body that help you
recover when you're ill M but that's but
that's only if you believe that he did
like God did that's only if you believe
Allah actually gave it to you right of
course but for me my road through right
now I don't no no no you no no no but it
does because you from the necessary
being and you you except all powerful
therefore who else created your heart
does it goes back to him who else go to
you have your whole body is made of DNA
DNA is a program yes that is so complex
yes there are three billion letters in
the gene The genome yes okay those
letters have switch buttons on and off
that make your heart you know every
single DNA has the same three billion
letters it's only the the the gene the
letters that it turns off and on that
makes your heart your heart liver your
liver your kidney your kidney so the
question is this if there's information
in the DNA it requires intelligence
who's that intelligence it has to be
Allah so what I'm saying is the one who
makes your heartbeat the one who makes
you breathe the one who gives you this
food and the water that you drink yes
the fact that you can even taste imagine
we had to eat food and it was painful we
enjoy food yeah all of these things that
God has created in you he deserves to be
woried he deserves to be worshiped
because of who he is let alone what he
does forget if all the stuff that he
does for you because of who he is do you
know how big the universe is have you
seen the UN have you seen the video that
shows our planet and then have you seen
that that is who the creator of the
heavens on Earth is he he deserves
worship 24/7 not five times a day 24/7
but he's only told us five times a day
he should be we should worship Him the
moment we WE born till we die but he
only ask us to pray five times a day so
once you acknowledge the respect you
give Ronaldo Allah is there is no
comparison between Ronaldo and Allah
Allah is the creator of the heavens and
Earth that's why he deserves us to
listen to
him okay does it make
sense it makes sense but there's I maybe
it's my bias it's there's just something
in me
that it's I think it's also because I've
um the your points I've heard it before
i' I've watched it all I watched you
mention all your points now you're
watching me live yeah exactly but the
difference it's it's because I think I
went from a point of
um uh acting what you say to not
accepting what you say that it makes it
even more like hard for me to accept
what you say now because I it feels like
exactly my ground is unstable but what
what what but no it's not unstable like
like let me be honest yeah you're not a
skeptic you're not an extreme skeptic
you believe in certain logical when you
wake up in the morning do you say I'm in
Pluto no you know you're in your house
yeah if you open your fridge and see a
rabbit would you not say that's weird
why do I have a rabbit in my fridge yeah
yeah of course so you use you use your
logical rational faculties when it comes
to your day-to-day basis why is it when
it comes to logical things pertaining to
God you become an extreme skeptic all of
a sudden why is it when your day-to-day
life today you logically knew you had to
be somewhere in 30 minutes you knew you
had to go and do that and come back here
used logic you used your car you drove
you didn't come and say I'm not in my
car maybe I'm in The Matrix maybe I am
in Mars maybe I'm not even I don't even
ex I'm taking the red pill maybe
whatever it is yeah exactly whatever it
is the blue P exactly so you use logic
throughout everything why is it when it
comes to the most logical thing that God
exists you're like I don't know do you
get what I'm trying to say yeah I get
what we have to be consistent so
consistency requires this makes sense
I'm not saying this to you know so you
can say wow Ali is such an amazing
orator I'm not I'm just saying logically
it follows tell me something logically
against it I'll accept it come and say
Ali no your premise is wrong because of
this I accept it whoever your friend
Cosmic skeptic I don't care who the hell
is I I'll face anyone you know why cuz
logic will I don't care who's a
professor spoke to the people who are um
um physicists
whatever logic logic is logic is
logic so there must be something else
what is it that's led to you to say okay
Islam cannot be the truth what led
because it's not even Islam you said you
you stop believing in God before not now
because now you accept the necessary
being okay so
um I when I when I was converted this
not an answer to your question but it's
about what you said so when I was uh
converted I used to pray here as well on
the Fridays inah you're going to pray
again who knows maybe in in and um every
time I prayed for about maybe six months
I prayed sometimes like once a day maybe
Max every time I prayed there was just
even though I already converted I've
heard all the like so much information
yeah yeah uh and I accepted what you
said in your video back then um about
umary what did you say I can't talk so
fast about the necessary being and and
about about looking in your fridge and
there's a rabbit in it that's not
logical you use logic so I used logic I
accepted even though I didn't feel the
the belief because belief is something
it's from within it's not it's connected
to logic but it's not just based on
logic exactly this is where I think
there's an issue logic I didn't believe
I can't like every time I I went down I
said why am I doing this this this is
not okay all right even though I
logically accepted it and that's why
right now when I'm with you and I try to
logically accept it there's still
something inside me I think I think let
me tell you something I don't believe it
still the belief is not there but there
two it's not just only the logic
sometimes have as we should establish
relation and should come
from to the Creator now here I think
maybe the people who give you
da people who with you maybe were
talking about loic arguments and like
this I'm not always in favor of the loal
arum except for those who are ston
things and you're not yeah yeah it
depends on the person they should
be part of our da is to make the people
to love their creator as well part of
our Vis to love Allah to do it out of
love to Allah not just only because I
worship Allah because I fear him which
is true I worship Allah because I
believe in him because logically he is
there it's not that we're talking about
we worship Allah because we love him as
well we love Allah we love Allah more
than our father our mother everyone love
Allah and the prophet sallallah alaihi
was he said no one would be a True
Believer Allah and his mer will more
dear to him more beloved to him than his
father than his mother than his children
than the people of the
world and then
when I I love you more than my father my
mother my children but not myself you
say said like that he said no one will
be a he repeated this to him even more
than yourself and then he thought about
it then he said and I love you I love
Allah and his messenger more than myself
why did you change he said I remember my
and I remember the I remember your death
and I the man you are the messenger of
Allah so the point is that of course we
should have to to to have this relation
of love between us and Allah because we
all we want Allah to forgive our sins
want Allah to help us in our life Etc
and I give this example which is today
told you and what percentage on Earth
that Allah would send a brother in this
isolated place I don't know where it is
then he booked Us in the middle of
nowhere the hotel yeah and Allah brought
this brother there to us Subhan Allah
and I said it's a Dua because we know we
believe in Allah and we see this we see
it on a daily basis it's not just only
one incident two incident three we see
it we see Allah saved us from calamities
from catastrophes we see us Allah has
saved us we see this we see this with
our eyes we see we we feel it we feel
his pres and everything around us yeah
it's not just only because we we
logically we we know about him it's
about actually we feel everything that
happens we saw the mercy of Allah you
know the most important thing you see
how Allah is merciful and how we love
Allah just look when you get married in
the future and then you will see how
much your wife cares about her children
because you didn't appreciate your
mother as much as you see when you see
yourself how your wife treating your
children at that point you will realize
how much your mother spend time and you
didn't see this and you see that in the
night so we think about it why this
woman will will will take the will bear
the pain in pregnancy will take the pain
someone think about it someone put her
in a pain that the women some women they
barely die while they're giving birth
can imagine someone put them into nearly
death and as soon as they when they when
they go back to their conscious the
first thing they want to do to hug that
child
yeah it doesn't make sense in any
anything even for us as men think about
it I say for example if if I have for
example appendix or something the first
would to get rid of it
if the one will hug will hug their child
not just that they will defend them with
their lives and I see them sometime when
I I look at in the night sometimes
sometimes you know what some because the
so in the beginning the child they they
don't sleep in night and and I have only
my 4 hours and sometimes I go to sleep
somewhere else yeah and I see her like
Subhan Allah yeah in the night she will
wake up like as soon as the baby C she
will wake up just to breastfeed the
child to turn the child and then she is
already exhausted which is two days ago
she G birth to the child and yet she is
in pain she is in all of these things
and that she would wake up to do this
forward M what put in her heart
to love this this creature yeah and on
top of this this guy who's going to grow
up like my son is going to be so
defant he's going to cause their problem
she had to call me like even from from
there from Britain or something they
said please deal with him yeah and I
remember the time that she was dealing
with with with with him when she was
when you in the early stage of of his
life and then look at just only think
about and say why how Allah Allah put
Mercy in her heart that means there
isn't her nature are something that
Allah planted in her to have that Mercy
to have that kindness to have that
emotion towards that child to protect
that child to care about that
child just this and Allah is more
merciful than upon us and the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he gave this
example he saw a woman you know during
the battlefield and that one was she was
scared she was looking around and then
she saw that one saw her child she
hugged that child you know in the middle
of the wall people fighting each other
and then she was hugging him protecting
him her child and then the prophet Sall
said do you see this woman will throw
her child in the fire would she would
she do that they said no she would never
do it because she would she literally
put her life in danger to protect her
child and then he said Allah is more
merciful upon us than this woman towards
her child if you think about this then
you'll know the merage of Allah that so
it's not just about logical argument
logic you know it's it's not about logic
yeah I have I have focused on that as
well yeah and I don't think that's the
issue with you it's not no I mean I have
also focused on the this what you what
you just said about about um how do you
say alhamdulillah
in like praise like thank thankfulness
because what he gave us I focused on as
well what he gave us to who it was not
sufficient why why why was it not
sufficient because the only way it's not
sufficient is if you truly understand
what Allah does for you it's impossible
for you say it's insufficient let me
give you an example here if I gave you
£5,000 today and I said to you every day
I'm going to send £5,000 to your account
would you be grateful to me yeah okay
what if I said to you I have a mansion
five-bedroom house you to live in it
yeah but that but this is again this is
logic logically coming to that point not
logically it's also more in the sense of
what Allah does because you said I done
the sense of gratitude but it didn't it
wasn't enough how could it not be enough
if it if it follows like what I'm saying
is yeah how could one not be grateful if
I did a favor for you you would be
grateful am I right or wrong yeah yeah I
would be grateful okay would you not
would you not have what do you what are
you folks that that I didn't that I
didn't really fully believe no no I'm
not saying that I'm not because I feel
like that's then the no no no I'm was
the thing no no I'm not making a
judgment if you fully believe or not I
don't know that it can be or cannot be
what I'm saying is if I do you a favor
would you not have some kind of an
emotional attachment to me where I would
okay good yeah so it's not just logical
it's not like okay he did something for
me but it's more of an emotional
attachment where it's like man he didn't
have to do that I mean he's such a good
person you will say that yeah you would
not would you think I'm a bad person if
I said to you look I want to give you
5,000 the first thing you say is what
does he want from me MH okay if I say to
you I don't want nothing from you just
take it yeah would you not think okay
he's a good man yeah okay so if I come
and say to you listen I'm going to say
5,000 send £5,000 to your account every
week yeah and then if I gave you a car
and if I gave you a house would you not
say why is this man doing this for me
mhm would you you not say that did you
not come to me one day and say Ali like
like I appreciate thank you why are you
doing this for me if I say to you
nothing I just I just want goodness for
you would you not increase in love as a
brother to
me I feel like that's a very personal
point I don't know if I no personally
put yourself in this yeah well I don't
even know if I I experienced love at all
okay but like for anybody I swear that's
fine that's fine but what I'm exper any
for any no I don't I don't know for sure
he experiened any love for anybody what
I'm saying is this have you got your
parents in your life yeah both Mom and
Dad yeah okay uh how's your relation
with
them fairly good okay it's like I cannot
complain compared to other people yeah
it's good all right so so if you
understand because sometimes people
don't know what the definition and they
think that because they don't know what
it is they think they don't have it but
they do but they just of course
definition of love my point my point is
this bro is that if I did all of those
stuff for you you'd be grateful to me if
I called you if I said listen Adam I
need your help you would help you would
comble you said listen what do you need
exactly when do you need of course I
would help you good so what I'm saying
is that that thing that I've done for
you would be enough yeah yeah yeah so
how is what if I say to you I'm going to
give you 10 million pound but tomorrow
you're not going to wake up would you
take it no why not that means your life
is more valuable than 10 million who
gives you that
life I don't know for sure and I think
that's and I think it's based on that I
didn't know for sure back then as well
based on our logical argument is Allah
that gives that life meaning 10 million
is not enough for me to ask you for your
life not a billion pounds if I say to
you I'll give you the entire Earth it's
not enough which means the one who's giv
you life you should be far greater to
him than any money that I give you it
has to follow because if I give you
£5,000 and you're telling me yeah thank
you I love you brother thank you very
much Etc I give you a house Allah has
given you a life that you will not
replace if I say to you I'll give you
one trillion pounds but tomorrow you're
going to die you say I don't want it
meaning the life that you have is more
precious who is giving you that life
Allah if Allah's giving you this life he
deserv worship why we go why we go
further even if I told you we'll give
you this let's say 1 billion EUR or
whatever but you know you will lose your
eyes tomorrow mhm will you replace that
never your no I would take it exactly so
meaning even not just life even if you
still alive Yeah by losing you losing
your eyes will not accept you still God
has given you the eyes to see ability to
look ability to hear and you can never
be and you can never repain for that by
the way so but then then I ask why when
I was when I was uh praying and I
converted yeah I feel like three years
yeah three years of daily researching is
kind of enough to yeah okay to no it's
not enough why it's not enough can you
finish your sentence why what why then
why didn't I believe I didn't no no we
the you didn't believe no I didn't
believe or at least I didn't feel it I
didn't feel it okay you feel like you
didn't believe I feel I feel like I
didn't believe even though I accepted
the logic okay good and that's why I
feel like God okay so so what it means
is like it can be like Allah says in the
Quran to the bedin he says they said we
have believed they said don't say you
have believed say you have
submitted IM is a whole different thing
I believe you submitted I thought
logically makes sense yep okay one God
yeah perfect but Iman is something that
you work for did you need to make Dua
did you use to pray to God did you use
to speak to God yeah what would you ask
if if you mind me asking is there
anything specific you would ask to give
me certainty certainty to give me uh
more strength more belief okay that kind
of stuff okay all right while would say
is personally bro I would say that's the
lacking part I think logically bro you
logically I think logically makes sense
about God existence there's ample of
evidence I think your of course I will
have to find it out myself more I have
to it is it is but I would say bro read
on the concepts that you yeah yeah you
can look I've spoken about that there's
like to me I have no doubt about I don't
think anybody would rebuke that what I'm
saying is though I think the spiritual
aspect is missing here it's because it's
everything's become too logical and in
Islam it's like like not everything is
logic of course there aspect but we
believe IM let me tell I can bring you
uncles full-blown old uncles Somali or
Kurdish or Bengali uncles I promise you
nobody can sway their faith if an
atheist came and said a big bang this
say yeah shut up man I don't know what
you're talking about you crazy
man they and this shows me this is where
I noticed you know some
people is from Allah it's not a logical
thing you have these elderly people you
can bring them all the things they'll
say you know what it shows you that
genuinely sometimes we need to question
our heart when the heart is has diseases
we need to work on that once we get rid
of those things and whatever other
factors there is Allah will give you
guidance let me tell you something even
if somebody comes and gives you
something like you said to me yeah like
I'm in a place where I'm certain in
faith in my faith why because I have
logical reasons and I believe in I have
some kind of Faith so when someone comes
to me with this I'll say you know what
majority of the religion makes sense to
me this little but okay I'm going to
look into I'm not going to sway myself
because you get it so what I'm saying is
I think that aspect is missing and I
think internally look and think what can
it be and have the communication with
God Allah says in the Quran I respond to
the caller that calls upon me he doesn't
say the Muslim he says the caller that
calls upon me I think today you should
go home and you forgot how to pray we'll
give you a where's a m g I have a map at
home one of these not one not oh this is
the the teaching M huh okay not these
brother this is a special M there we go
so this is from us if you return back to
Islam inshallah but I would say bro turn
to Allah look you need to treat Allah
like like come you know like the Sal
it's so hard to to do that if you look
it's not don't make it hard for yourself
something that's easy is it hard for you
to go home today and say Allah if you
are there I'm looking for guidance guide
me is it hard no sincerely sincerely
sincerely he doesn't have sincerity
because he said the idea is the the
point is what he think he do what he
does I will tell you something I know
because when you are skeptic about it
calling someone you will will never get
the answer the the idea is literally you
sincere you know you from your heart
you're asking the guidance there is a
man he can do that there is a there is a
scholar actually he was making logical
arguments about Islam and things like
this in the past yeah and he made like
100 reasons 100 reasons debunking the
people who disbelieve in God he made 100
you know reasons wow one reasons that
makes you know to believe in God about
about you know certainty to believe in
God and he by nasur which is naur you
know know it is inban these areas and
then so an old woman she was in the in
the they said come come there is this
color such and such he's coming in the
Town M he said why what's what's theim
he said he found he he's the one who
authored the book that contains 100
reasons yeah to believe in God then this
old lady what she said if he didn't have
100 doubts out believing in God he will
not author a book about believing in God
in 100 years yeah probably and he left
that and he said this statement he said
that day he literally burned his book
and he said oh Allah give me a faith
like the faith of the elderly women in
like this I want like this I want to
believe like this because the the point
is we could we could keep bringing you
logical arguments things that not Lal
but at the end of the day at the end of
the day we cannot penetrate your heart
we can open your heart we cannot make
you to be sincere in what you say so
that's why when we saying to you if you
are if Allah knows sincerity in you
Allah will guide you true if Allah knows
I will tell you something and that's how
it is if Allah knows Allah says in the
Quran Allah Allah when we see the
Quran meaning the one who struggle in
our path will guide them our way and we
and we will not guide the wrong doers
and Allah said Allah will never gu them
meaning so if Allah knows you have
sincerity in your heart you could
convince I'm sincere you know yourself
it's not about you know pretending
because Allah knows what's in your heart
so if you are sincere to Allah asking
Allah sincerely to guide you to open
your heart then Allah will do do that
look I would say believe leave on that
if not I do that and I think you got
nothing to lose Bro Look if you're
sincere like I did this before I came to
Islam I said look I know there's a high
power I said if you are there show me
which is a religion Christianity Islam
judism I don't care whichever one it is
you are sincere I'm sure you are it's
just you're a bit like I don't know but
you know there's a higher power there in
necess ask just say if you are there
please guide me bro if you're sincere
you got nothing to lose if you do that
now the only thing is Allah will send
you signs it's upon you to take them and
reject them now that is on you sure I'll
I'll do it tonight I'll ask the signs
part of the signs I will say to you that
you coming here em sorry you coming here
today yes MH and Allah you see it as a
sign you mean yeah 100% what's more than
this forget that forget that sh are you
telling me it's a coincidence that
brother randomly goes answer his
question where is he is he here or
noen but he I'm pretty sure he heard me
and me my friend talk listen listen dep
for you think that listen there's
something further than this how did come
how did we come here I met him randomly
I don't know him I never met him in my
life yeah there so there's so much
things going on of course something is
going to happen like that listen I met
him randomly in the height Park last
week on Sunday and he said to me I'm
from I'm I'm from I said Subhan Allah we
are planning to go to Holland to
Netherlands we going to rdam and then we
planning to go to amdam we didn't
arrange with the brother fromer Dam yet
and then he said to me he's going to
arrange it and he was after not just
that he was planning to arrange
where in Amsterdam and he didn't he
couldn't get hold of them and then he
said that's all local M here they they
can arrange it here so he arranged it
here not in not in the city yeah and we
came but if if it was in Amsterdam there
would be probably someone that converted
or has been converted also maybe maybe
no no the fact that it wasn't the issue
is this to the fact that it wasn't it
was here that brother so he didn't even
speak he didn't you didn't you don't
know him no but he he heard me talking
with him no problem still the fact that
he we this could have ended with okay we
have to go the fact that he could have
ended with anything that's the thing
okay now the problem here just because
it ended like this doesn't mean now this
is this is this is this depends on how
you see it if you have this this is the
problem now now I'm going to tell you're
going to say I don't have it in my heart
or don't believe in that's the fact that
what you're doing is the fact that
you're looking at things and instead of
saying there could be a chance that
actually this could there could be a
chance it's but you don't you are more
on the other side of no but other fact
is that it could have been like because
I've been believing that for three years
of course the problem do you see what
I'm saying you have built a habit in
your head that it's it's as if if we was
to if the Angels were to descend you
would say this is just some kind of
usion it's come to the point where it's
like if we was to
say God is going to speak to you and say
I am God you say now that's just some
sound it's become to the point where
it's as if you're like I don't want to
believe like if you brought me the
angels and the Hereafter we went on a
trip and we saw the he hell in heaven
yeah you'll say bro it's VR visual
reality do you get what I'm trying to
say so you need to work on that you need
to think to yourself why am I always
justifying it to not it can be other
possibility other possibility can it be
God no so it's all possibilities but
cannot be a sign why can sign be the
option you get no because I don't
believe in Islam and that's why I don't
see it as an option that's fine but what
I'm saying is why is it that all other
possibilities but not God why can it not
be God why can it not be that the one
who because I don't believe what do you
mean we logically showed you necessary
being you accepted necessary being you
accepted attributes you've really
accepted no but i' I've told you the
complicated thing with that that's the
problem you didn't tell you did not tell
me no one Adam tell one Oneal argument
you made against the argument tell me
one we don't have to discuss that
because they're let's say I have a
conversation with one of these men here
okay and they are not as educated as you
are so I talk with them and somehow I
convince them yeah okay yeah how like if
I if I convince him that doesn't mean
that he's wrong true because because you
have a certain type of argument where I
just know you have so much more
knowledge than I am and that's very nice
bro something coming from nothing no but
wait but wait does you need to be a
smart person to say yes or no to that
but no because when I was with my friend
and that was logical how he said it so
does he believe that something come from
nothing he's out of he I don't exactly
know what he said but he have he said
something just because he doesn't have a
yes or no answer that's why I can't just
embrace it and tell it to you it's more
difficult than that it's not just point
blank I I I understand but that's the
hard the hard part you can't just accept
it like that I understand I have to read
into the points I have to check both
sides I can't just accept just because
you made a good argument that that AR I
made argument I made a logical argument
listen you said nothing toal arguments
not good AR logical argument no no
because I can make a logical argument to
him wait wait wait no no he's correct
you can you can make AAL argum he does
and that he believes me and it still is
not a logical argument but it's a good
argument so that could be for you as
well we don't know but you cannot ever
tell him you cannot ever convince him or
he can convince you that something can
come from nothing you don't need to be a
smart guy for that can something come
from nothing I convin so many people
that something can canot come from
nothing as well of course one 1 + 1
equals 2 and zero doesn't equals one
thank you so you know that nothing from
nothing nothing comes yeah zero do you
believe something can come from
nothing no good so look anyone would
agree in the park in the whole world you
go they will say to you yeah from
nothing nothing comes but it's not a
matter of being smart it's logical well
I I've never seen something that comes
from thank you that's why it's logical
so imagine if someone came and said no
no I believe something comes from
nothing does that mean now because you
made a smart argument he doesn't know if
you went to somebody else no nothing
well nothing comes well my friend he
told me something else he said B why did
you treat this friend like a prophet you
you keep talking to like like you treat
his friend like he's a prophet bro bring
him to me I promise you I promise you I
give my I don't I don't want to sound
arrogant I promise you he will have
nothing to say I promise you I will stay
here an extra day bring him to my face
okay if I speak to him and I debate him
and he cannot answer would you change
your mind or would you say he has to we
have to go to Cosmic skeptic now we we
sure surely have to go go to cosm
skeptic but if no no wait wait how could
I win if if you convince him yeah if I
convince him then now I need to go to
cos skeptic no no then then I will take
I will actually take it seriously I will
I will go and uh research Islam again
okay no problem if I speak to him and if
I can debunk him I already called him
you can't no he doesn't want to meet me
no no he's not able to no no I will stay
an EXT today not to you stay EXT today
yes I ask him okay ask him I will come
to him anywhere if I debate him and
logically it doesn't follow any makes no
sense you would look into Islam of
course okay I'm staying extra day yes I
will I'm staying extra day let me know
when I'm going to change my ticket yes
give me you got my number yeah let me
know when I'll come from rdam to I was
going to go somewhere else I'm that okay
don't change it yes I I ask him day I'll
wait for you yeah but he no you don't
even have to you can he has work in the
morning and then he's he would be able
he said If he if he would no problem no
problem you arrange it how old is your
uh 24 where's he from is he Dutch yeah
he's can he speak English yeah he's
perfect that's what I need but don't say
oh my English is not good no of course
yeah perfect thank you Adam it was a
pleasure man thank you too nice me you
thank you no har feelings thank you for
the food and everything no no it's a
pleasure Man
one and how did you know